takes courage to confront inner
challenges also takes courage to
confront
outer challenges there are a lot of
outer challenges that require
real courage not just looking in on
ourselves so that's important sometimes
but looking out in this country a huge
one
is that our elites who have taken all
that power feel no responsibility to our
american traditions or
the american people broadly they
consider the american people to be
deplorable
irredeemable bitter clinging rubes and
idiots and neo-nazis
who should not be able to speak in
public up to and including
the former president of the united
states donald trump gave a speech at
cpac the conservative
political action conference where he
talked about
many of the problems facing the country
questions about the election
what he might do in 2024
youtube will not permit this video on
the internet
so there was a a channel just
one channel among many posted the video
they had it taken down they were not
not allowed to broadcast it then there
was a question was it just this channel
or is youtube more broadly youtube has
now clarified
they've said that unless users add
countervailing viewpoints about trump's
speech they won't allow trump's speech
up there
so for instance i could play trump's
speech right now
on this channel as long as after he
talks i say
he's wrong he's bad orange man bad if i
do that then i'm allowed to have
trump speech on youtube but if i don't
or if i say yeah well i made some pretty
good points
that video will be taken down youtube
says we enforce our community guidelines
consistently
regardless of speaker or political
leaning they're just as consistent i
think as the washington post
joe biden showers money on americans
trump
braces us all for economic pain
in accordance with our established
presidential election integrity policy
established as of what like five minutes
ago which prohibits content uploaded
after the say harvard deadline claiming
widespread fraud
uh changed the outcome of the 2020 u.s
presidential election we removed
this video from rsbn
they're they're barely even mustering a
justification for this
they never took down any videos of
stacey abrams and other people claiming
that that election was stolen
because stacey abrams is a democrat they
never took down any videos of hillary
clinton
and other prominent democrats claiming
that that election was stolen
after the safe harbor deadline because
those people are democrats
but they will take down any any speech
that they find threatening
to their political agenda from donald
trump or other republicans
because they enjoy the privileges of
being elites and controlling
the flow of information around the
internet but they have no sense
of responsibility to the american way of
life
they actually don't like those american
traditions they want to get rid of those
and institute their own new guidelines
this is
the thesis of my book which i explain
in painstaking detail it's called
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
i actually do sort of suspect that this
book
is going to face censorship from the
left not because it's some outrageous
raucous shock jock kind of book it's not
at all
but i think that's actually the point
the book very
consistently shows you what the left has
done
how the development of this political
correctness and the censorship
is different than conservatives have
traditionally understood it
and and the book i think explains how if
we if we want to fight it effectively
which we haven't done for
now 100 years we need to radically
change course
i think they're probably going to go
after that sort of thing so i recommend
you pre-order it by the way
before before they take it down because
the left is now emboldened to use their
privilege to stop
any threats to their rule if you enjoyed
that video be sure to hit the subscribe
button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube knows that we've got
the absolute top content out there
[Music]
[Music]
you